a regular girl like
i'm i'm not so like if you are going to
date me like either you got to be able
to handle that or you yourself also have
to not be like regular like i don't
think i'm like just an average person
like that is boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an 8 carat
christian cut vintage engagement ring if
you make 45 000 a year it would take
what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to do that it's
good blind people that's so superficial
that's like so superficial but it's
about so much more than that it's about
the fact that you can afford that right
i go to yoga with this girl who's an
eight-carat diamond engagement ring yeah
with the weed company and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that okay
well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling they're not but not
not in a good way not in a good way i'm
telling you like my dad would but if my
mom asked for that from my dad my dad
would have told her to go find a new
boyfriend because there was no way in
hell he was gonna spend two hundred
thousand dollars on an engagement ring
and that's
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he went you said he's built to the
becoming that he wasn't that originally
right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no
no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i know
for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend you know what
it means like i need somebody who can be
on that level
right but the problem is like guys don't
care about your money
right around there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this like to
me these are like crazy high standards
so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
who mm-hmm your dating coach married yes
because she has a baby and her wedding
ring is at least five carats yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with me maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
being someone that can make that amount
of money in a shorter period of time
like somebody who would say a musical
artist right a musical producer somebody
who's in entertainment somebody who's on
a tv show somebody who
does like concerts and tours that amount
of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
eazy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it
no but like this is something coming
from someone like i've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
like i but i would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money i
i mean
here's the thing if i can afford it
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
going to need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else
[Music]
are you okay
that's horrible
i'm sorry but that is horrible
she's number one missing the point she's
looking at things that i can talk really
really doesn't i'm sorry she's going to
be in a very unhappy relationship she's
if she finds that person
it's all based on whatever is exterior
there's there she doesn't care about
anything deeper and that's that's i'm
very i feel sorry for her she doesn't
actually know what's important
and i i really feel for the men like
guys who have so much they're working so
hard they're trying to prove themselves
because society makes them
because you have to
make your way in society you have to do
so much to prove yourself these days
and to have this girl come here and just
completely belittle you on the internet
these are good men out there
and and they don't just they they they
don't deserve you you don't even deserve
a mcdonald's from them
i'm sorry but
you
it's not about the dollar sign
it's about the intention
i would love even if
who cares about the food if a guy takes
me to mcdonald's and then buys me a meal
amazing
i love mcdonald's
like what's wrong with that
it's the intention it's the fact that he
made made a point and said hey i've got
this
i want to take you out i want to get you